tous les jours, je demande ce que je peux faire pour
glenview c'est pourquoi j'ai fondé
le club de course la table espagnole au
centre communautaire condesa tu penses que
l'oxy un non et le quartier regarde
ça se desserrer après cette courte sorte
de rupture de la portion de glace de  soyez
désolé d'être la roue qui grince, mais
ne serait-il pas plus amusant de
briser la glace en petits cubes, puis de
verser du scotch sur lui il y a de nouvelles années
voulait devenir membre du
département de police de Glen View vous êtes un
maniaque homicide était  Je ne ressens pas l'ambiance
J'ai ce scénario dans mon esprit et une
femme au foyer asiatique sexy seule la nuit mieux
appelle la surveillance du quartier et ensuite elle
suce bien Mary Je suis également intéressé par
ce qui m'arrive
Allons voir avec la soeur qu'est-ce que c'est  Hé les
gars, j'ai trouvé quelque chose il y a une invasion extraterrestre qui
s'est produite chérie laisse juste la
police s'en occuper n'importe laquelle de ces personnes
pourrait être un
extraterrestre  par
la bouche désolé hé maman essaie d'
impressionner la maison de mes amis essaie de rencontrer Chut
dis moi des extraterrestres bébé d'accord je ne peux
faire confiance à personne regarde son visage regarde
mon visage regarde son visage et écoute
moi regarde le et écoute  moi le
regarde et comprends moi regarde nous deux
mais comprends personne n'a écouté mes
paroles et n'entends bien son
visage personne ne touche cet automne nous
découvrons ce que c'est
avant la vache mais cette chose est géniale
qui veut un vivaneau avec l'homme lézard